they've been traveling for days they are
weary they are worn they've been
terrified but at least now they're safe
it's a harrowing experience for them for
sure these are some of the thousands of
afghans that fled kabul they got out
where so many have failed and are still
failing many leaving families behind
some creating them amidst the chaos and
the misery i mean that and mom is so
happy because the baby is so healthy
this baby born as its family fled kabul
heading to a u.s air base in germany the
mother went into labor in the air
suffering complications now here in the
u.s she and her child are doing fine
they're so happy that they
are here
and
their family is safe nearly 11 000
people have been evacuated from
afghanistan in just a 12 hour period the
majority are coming into dallas the big
international airport near washington dc
we feel unsafe on them we just came here
they were put on buses and driven their
first few miles on american soil to an
expo center what was a trickle is now a
flood of people each with their own
harrowing terrifying tales these bosses
are now arriving fairly regularly
perhaps one every hour every hour and a
half the refugees get off they go into
the convention center but this is not
their final stop this is simply a
layover somewhere they can get something
to eat somewhere they can use the
facilities they will then go on to
places like texas like wisconsin and
even further afield their journey here
in the united states has only just begun
so they will let us know here or there
this man hasn't heard from his wife
since she left kabul you have to just
wait and find out where she ends up
landing
i'm sorry you're going through that he
tells his story to hanessa she is
hearing a lot of these an afghan
interpreter with a local muslim support
group she was at the airport helping
those refugees make sense of their new
surroundings she has heard some
harrowing tales a lot of these people
have made it to safety but they've had
to leave their families behind and they
don't know what's happened to them yes
it's it's really traumatizing because
they had to pick and choose who was
going to come with them even the people
who went to the airport not everybody
was able to get on the planes across the
street a flooring business is now
leading the local effort to get
essentials to refugees from
toys to snacks
underwears jan an afghan refugee himself
is working non-stop to get packs ready
donations are turning up almost every
minute we're all here to help
we're all humans we see what's going on
over in afghanistan
and so for those who find themselves
spending their first night in what is
going to be their new home there is so
much to make sense of so many questions
so many worries so much relief they have
made it many others will not phil
lavelle al jazeera in chantilly virginia